nous continuons aujourd'hui la
présentation d'un certain nombre de
personnalités politiques représentant
les différentes tendances
engagé dans la campagne électorale
aujourd'hui monsieur alain krivine de la
ligue communiste
alain krivine vous êtes alain krivine un
fils de bourgeois
votre père était dentiste cela dit vous
n'êtes pas de ses fils à papa qui font
joujou à l'extrême gauche parce qu'ils
sont fâchés avec leurs parents il existe
dans votre famille
une tradition d'extrême gauche votre
père tremplin si que vos quatre frères
étaient communistes nous sommes servis
de la présentation d'alain krivine lors
de l'émission armes égales du mois de
décembre pour faire le portrait du
leader politique pour nous les portraits
individuels dans aucun intérêt chez la
même plus loin sont dangereux on en a
fait une curieuse expérience il ya pas
longtemps avec le portrait du premier
ministre je crois qu'il vaut mieux ne
pas insister là dessus parce que c'était
clair pour tout le monde les joueurs ont
un exemple si vous faisiez d'aumale
portrait de nixon pas semblablement
pourriez montrer nixon comme un charmant
garçon offrant des cadeaux à ses enfants
bon père de famille le soir de noël
sauf que le véritable portrait dixon ça
doit te portera d'un assassin pour un
accueil villes c'est le portrait de la
ligue qui compte avant tout revenons à
laurence passant toute la ligue
n'existait pas encore et des transfuges
de l'union des étudiants communistes
avaient fondé deux ans auparavant
un nouveau mouvement d'extrême gauche
à l'époque le public connaissez mieux
comme un dj snorre sauvageau que krivine
quel a été le rôle de son mouvement à
l'époque notre organisation s'appelle la
jeunesse communiste révolutionnaire
nous étions essentiellement implanté
dans le milieu étudiant nous avons dix
ont joué le rôle que pouvait jouer une
organisation révolutionnaire en
participant à toutes les manifestations
du mouvement étudiant en essayant de
donner une dimension politique en
faisant en sorte que nos militants
jouent un certain rôle ils ont dans
l'encadrement des manifestations et de
toutes les initiatives nous pensions
qu'en 68 il aurait fallu aller plus loin
passer à l'étape supérieure
c'est à dire que tous les salariés
s'organisent sur les lieux de la
production en comité regroupant
l'ensemble des nervis de façon à pouvoir
proposer aux structures de l'état
bourgeois nuit étaient des structures
vivre de nouvelles structures
complètement différentes des structures
pour les tares yens c'est à dire ces
fameux comités de base atteint les
travailleurs ont vu que
personne n'était prêt à prendre ses
responsabilités en 68 et bien injuste
dit ils ont arrêté la guerre et s'était
terminée le 12 juin 68 la jcr et 10 août
et en juillet alain krivine avec
d'autres camarades du mouvement est
arrêté sous l'inculpation de
reconstitution de ligue dissoute
ils sortent après cinq semaines de
détention à temps morts 69 que la ligue
communiste est créé elle se présente
comme la section française de la
quatrième internationale créée par léon
trotsky
en 1938 elle compte aujourd'hui cinq
mille adhérents
vous pouvez génie et vous gémir et
encore du rqra de tout acabit
car désormais une nouvelle génération
révolutionnaire est né en france et dans
tous les pays du monde qui n'acceptent
plus cette politique de capitulation 1
qui en ce qui nous concerne elle prête
aujourd'hui et se donne tous les moyens
pour reprendre jusqu'à la victoire
finale
le combat de mai et juin 1968
à rennes
bah
nous ne sommes plus maintenant une
organisation uniquement étudiants
débutants ou sommes nous ne sommes plus
une organisation de jeunesse seulement
mais nous sommes une organisation qui
comme toute organisation révolutionnaire
digne de ce nom
essaye d'intervenir dans tous les
domaines sont des boules des luttes anti
capitaine aux élections présidentielles
de 69 la ligue communiste présente un
candidat alain krivine qui est pour
beaucoup de français
les vitrines mai 68 la première fois un
militant révolutionnaire à la
possibilité de s'exprimer devant vous
cette possibilité n'est pas le résultat
d'une quelconque élection
l'utilisation de la télévision
développeront une question de principe
c'est à dire qu'au lieu de s'adresser
pendant des meetings à quelques
centaines ou quelques milliers de
personnes
nous nous adressons à des millions de
travailleurs mais à la différence disons
de tous les partis que nous qualifions
d' électoraliste
nous ne faisons pas croire à travers les
campagnes politiques électorales comme
celle qui va se dérouler maintenant que
c'est par les élections que c'est par le
bulletin ne va que nous arrivons à
instaurer le socialisme en france au
contraire nous utilisons la tribune de
la télévision ou la radio pour dénoncer
ce que nous appelons la farce électorale
c'est à dire cet immense mystification
cette façade caricature de démocratie
que représentent les élections dans le
système actuel
la ligue se fera entendre dans
différentes grandes manifestations
notamment pour le centre de la commune
et lors des obsèques gouverner je crois
que le plus bel exemple de l'unité des
groupes révolutionnaires
ça a était l'unité réalisée après
l'assassinât de notre camarade maoïste
aux vernets avec cet immense
manifestation ce qui a donné lieu je
prends un des plus grands événements
politiques en france parce que c'est
vrai que beaucoup de travailleurs
d'extrême gauche de travailleurs
combatif révolutionnaires sont un peu
inquiets de la division des groupes
d'extrême gauche
une manifestation comme celle d'obernai
a finalement renforcé la confiance des
travailleurs les plus combatives
je crois que c'est pas à la cie la
fameuse grève du joint français s'est
déclenchée quelques semaines après cette
démonstration de force ont fait la job
is you nerfs lors des obsèques du
diamaré loverde quels sont les rapports
de la ligue avec la classe ouvrière car
on nous a accusés d'être souvent rejetée
par l aujourd'hui nous intervenons
environ
250 usines ou bureaux mais aussi nos
camarades interviennent des syndicats et
surtout quand il y en a dans les mains
un des militants de la ligue qui est en
jeu explique les difficultés de cette
double appartenance
il ya d'une part la répression patronale
c'est à dire que les patrons n'accepte
pas souvent qu'un militant
révolutionnaire soit dans leur industrie
dans leur usine
il ya d'autre part le fait de ceux dont
on parlait tout à l'heure que les
directions syndicales ne voulant pas le
débat avec les révolutionnaires dans la
classe ouvrière
si un militant de la ligue est connu
trop tôt avant qu'il est disons secret
qu'il faut créer une certaine base
sociale dans l'entreprise où il
travaille peut être éliminée d'office et
ne peut plus ensuite militaire alors
nous ne faisons pas connaître tous nos
militants c'est à dire c'est qu'on
choisit le moment où on les fait
connaître
et qu'est ce qui vous distingue des
syndicats la lutte des classes à
outrance parce que tout ce que l'on peut
obtenir dans la classe ouvrière s'est
arrachée par là lui ça n'a jamais été
des choses octroyé comme on veut nous
faire croire actuellement avec la
politique des grès des contrats vous
allez vous présenter aux élections
oui je suis candidat et pour être élu
non absolument pas militant
révolutionnaire ne se présente jamais
pour est élu il se présente pour faire
une campagne politique 120 candidats
feront la campagne politique de la ligue
pour les communistes ils ne sont que des
marionnettes du pouvoir qui font le jeu
de la majorité en divisant les forces de
gauche pour nous n'est pas communiste
celui qui devrait mais vu ce qui s'est
passé l'évolution du parti communiste et
de l'ensemble du mouvement communiste
international
nous pensons que être anti communiste
celui qui s'oppose à la victoire du
socialisme dans un pays déterminé à
l'échelle mondiale celui qui est contre
le communisme et à ce moment là on peut
prendre quelques exemples
nous pensons par exemple que les
dirigeants du parti socialiste ont signé
le programme commun des gens comme
françois mitterrand des gens comme jules
ma c'est à dire des gens qui sont
opposés
révolution socialiste qui n'ont jamais
digéré que socialisme en chine ou en
union soviétique que qui n'ont pas
hésité lorsqu'il était ministre
je fais allusion à jules moch a tiré sur
des travailleurs que ces gens là sont
des anticommunistes en ce sens qu'ils
sont opposés aux communistes et à une
perspective socialiste en france
pourquoi aujourd'hui les certains
travailleurs ont peur du communisme ont
peur du socialisme et bellegarde
concrètement ce qui s'est passé en
mesure ce qui se passe en
tchécoslovaquie ou en pologne et ils
nous disent il le dit souvent au parti
communiste
si c'est ça le socialisme eh bien on
n'en veut pas maintenant on le patronat
pourrait se réjouir les violences 4
millions de la gauche est lourd mais
pour nous c'est par bonnet blanc et
blanc bonnet du dr et les andalous il ya
une différence
c'est pour ça aussi que dans une
consigne de vote au deuxième tour à laon
pour dumont amour et ceci sans terme aux
critiques pour autant dire que si
l'union de la gauche arrive au pouvoir
il y aura une situation de crise elle
qui vous sera favorable
bien sûr c'est une situation qui à coup
sûr pour permettre de stimuler
l'ensemble de l'it deux ouvrières les
travailleurs environ
même si cette façon justifiée déformée
mais vers où kylie a donc une force qui
se traduit qui existe qui vous un
changement
oui
c'est bien alain krivine je voudrais
vous demander deux choses d'abord ce que
vous pensez du film que vous venez de
voir
et ensuite si vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter aux déclarations que l'on vient
d'entendre dans ce fille puis je crois
qu'en huit minutes il n'était pas
possible pour les réalisateurs de
montrer toutes les autres activités de
la ligue notamment celles qui pour nous
sont extrêmement importantes à savoir le
travail quotidien d'implantation que
nous faisons dans les entreprises au
service des travailleurs notamment de
montrer l'activité de nos camarades dans
les syndicats qui ne sont pas là pour
détruire les syndicats comme trop
souvent on a voulu le dire mais au
contraire qui fait force dans les
syndicats de faire régner la démocratie
ouvrière notamment lorsqu'ils sont élus
à des postes de responsabilité et qui à
ce moment-là renforce considérablement
les syndicats et en font une arme de
tous les travailleurs
ceci dit par rapport à ce film je crois
qu'effectivement il nous faudrait
beaucoup plus que huit minutes mais de
longues heures pour pouvoir expliquer
aux travailleurs ce que sont les
révolutionnaires et non pas cette
poignée de casseurs ou de gauchistes
comme on a voulu le dire
ceci dit nous n'aurons pas la télévision
nous pouvons apparaître là de temps en
temps pendant les périodes électorales
mais je crois que on n'a aucune illusion
à seurre à la matière pour pouvoir
développer concrètement est complètement
notre programme
pour conclure je voudrais quand même
dire deux choses la première c'est que
il y à une catégorie de travailleurs qui
ne verront jamais cette émission ou qui
en tout cas ne connaîtront jamais nos
positions se sont tous les travailleurs
des colonies française de la martinique
de la guadeloupe de la réunion qui
jusqu'à présent n'ont pas pu voir
l'émission armes égales qui devait trop
dangereuse cette émission a été censuré
maintenant pour les travailleurs
parisiens qui voudrait avoir une vue
beaucoup plus complète des activités de
la ligue
eh bien je profite de la télévision
parce que nous n'avons pas l'argent
nécessaire comme lui des airs pour
placarder les murs de paris
eh bien je les invite à venir
massivement au meeting que nous
organisons au palais des sports le 7
février
je vous remercie m